Let’s put some of this into practice with
a real world image.
I am going to load an image of a scene that
comprises some tomatoes on a bush in a lab,
and I am going to convert the image so that
the pixels are stored inside MATLAB as double
precision numbers.
So we can have a look at the image as advertised:
it contains some tomatoes on a bush inside
a lab—at MIT, actually.
If I click around on the image we can see
that the pixels in the tomato have got quite
a large amount of red, 65 per cent red, not
much green, not much blue.
Now the leaves, the stems for instance, contain
more green than they do red or blue.
The tomato images are interesting; the tomatoes
are actually quite shiny and if I click around
here we see that the value is actually closer
to white than it is to red.
This region here we refer to as a specular
highlight.
What has happened is that bright light within
the room is reflecting off the surface of
the tomato in a specular rather than a defuse
fashion and in this case the light has not
picked up the color of the fruit, it is basically
what we are seeing here is the color of the
light source itself.
We have talked a couple of times already about
the process of gamma encoding the information
within an image in a file.
But what I would like to do is to undo that
gamma encoding; I would like to apply a gamma
correction or gamma decoding and I can do
that with the iread function by parsing in
an extra argument and parsing in the gamma
value that I would like to have applied to
every pixel.
So this will eliminate the non-linearity between
the luminance that the camera observed and
the pixel values that
I have in my MATLAB workspace.
If I display this gamma corrected image we
will see that it looks rather unusual, it
looks actually quite dark and as explained
before what has happened here is that the
gamma correction has now been applied twice.
I have applied it once in software and the
monitor that I am looking at the image on
is also applying the gamma correction.
So it doesn’t look right that the values
that I have in my workspace are now linearly
related to the light that went into the lens
of the camera.
So the next thing that I would like to do
is just to display one of the color planes
in this image.
So let’s display the red plane and here
it is here, and we can see that the tomato
fruits are looking quite bright here because
they reflect a lot of red light, whereas in
the green plane we see that the fruit looks
very, very, dark.
Let’s separate out the color values.
I am going to create a new workspace variable
called R which contains pixels in every row
and every column that belong to plane one.
I am going to do a similar thing for the green
plane and I am going to do a similar thing
for the blue plane, which is plane
number 3.
So, for instance, I can just display again
the green plane that I just computed.
Now the next thing that I want to do is to
compute the chromaticity coordinates and to
do that I need to compute the sum of the red
and the green and the blue and I am going
to put that into the local variable
called Y.
Y is a common symbol used for what is called
the luminance image; it’s a monochrome image
actually.
If we look at this now it will look something
like a monochrome or black and white picture
of the scene.
It is the average of all of the color channels.
Now the chromaticity coordinates computes
the ratio between all of the pixels in the
red plane and the sum and I can compute this
element wise division by using the MATLAB
operator dot slash, so what it is going to
do is to compute a new image, call it little
R, and its dimensions will be the same as
the dimensions of capital R and capital Y.
Each element of the image little R is the
corresponding pixel in capital R divided by
the corresponding pixel in capital Y.
And let me do the same thing for the green
chromaticity channel; let’s have a look
at these.
These are stored in the MATLAB workspaces
matrices, but of course I can display a matrix
as an image and an image is represented as
a matrix, so here is little R and I can create
another figure, figure two, and in figure
two I am going to display little G.
So these are the chromaticity values, and
if we poke around some of the values here
we can see that where the fruit is, it has
got quite a large value of R, it has a very
small value of little G.
If we look at where some of the leaves are
we see that they have got a modest value of
little R—about 0.39—and little G has got
a slightly bigger value, so these two images
represent the color in this scene: we have
factored out the intensity.
So let’s say now that we wanted to make
a rule that would select a pixel that belonged
to the fruit and didn’t belong to anything
else.
Well clearly we want a rule that said something
about the fact that R is quite big, it seems
to be at least greater than 0.8 and mostly
it is above 0.9, but let’s say, conservatively,
it has to be above 0.8 and in this case we
want the G value has to be quite small.
Has to be sort of, you know, less than 0.1
even.
But to be conservative, let’s say it has
to be less than 0.2.
So I could create a new variable, it is going
to be a logical variable, so I am going to
say anywhere that R is greater than 0.8 and
G is less than 0.2 it will be true.
So let’s display this image I just created
called Tom and there we have it.
The background here, these values are all
zero, they are all false and in here they
all have values of one, which is MATLAB’s
way of representing the concept of true.
We have created now a binary image where the
pixels are one if they are the tomato fruit
and they are zero if it is not the fruit,
background, people and leaves.
Now that we have a binary image we can do
a lot of the things that we demonstrated earlier
when we were talking about binary vision.
So I could look for all of the blobs that
are within this image so I apply the iblobs
function to the binary image we just computed
and here it is, that there are ten blobs in
here.
Now, there are clearly a couple of big blobs
and we can see there, there are some blobs
with quite a large area and there is also
a lot of very, very small blobs around the
edge of one of the fruit.
Now we can go back to the original image,
let’s have a look at figure one and there
I am going to display the original image and
then I am going to overlay some bounding boxes
and I will overlay them in the color green.
So there we have it; quite simply, we have
taken a color image, we have computed the
essential color at each of the pixels in terms
of chromaticity coordinates.
We have made a very simple rule to choose
pixels that belong to the fruit and not to
anything else; that led us to a binary image.
Once we have a binary image, then we can apply
all of the techniques that we have already
learnt and in very quick fashion I can outline
the particular fruit.
Now the problem with this is that the fruit
are kind of misshapen, part of that is because
of the specular reflection that I mentioned
earlier and also some of the fruit is obscured
by leaves and whatever, still the bounding
box is a good place to start, we could look
at some of the mathematical morphology techniques
that we used before, we could apply the techniques
of dilation and erosion perhaps to fill in
some of the missing part of those fruit.